chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett joins us now major good morning
good morning we heard Nancy say that we
will likely have nationally televised
impeachment hearings ahead of us with
this impeachment resolution what
actually changes now the country knows
when it's going to see some of the
depositions taken as transcripts that
they can read and evaluate themselves
Republicans keep saying they're not
going to be the indictment Democrats
have been describing for weeks now the
public will get to make its own
determination and as Nancy said there'll
be hearings but what we should pause for
a second to just reflect on the gravity
of the House vote yesterday everything
that looks divided bitterly in a
partisan way appears small the
Constitution is not it doesn't get
shrunk by a hard partisan vote like this
what matters is the House has set an
impeachment inquiry in motion that means
the tide for impeaching this president
at least in the house appears
irreversible that will be a historic
mark this house and this president will
never be able to walk away from the
White House is fighting this of course
major Garrett but there is frustration
our White House team has learned among
the aides with within the White House
because the messaging from the legal
team and then the comms team is not
always coordinated so overall how is the
White House pushing back the way it has
since President Trump was inaugurated
with the president and his twitter feed
the anxiety in the White House is the
impeachment story is larger than any
story the president has confronted much
larger than the Muller investigation it
will only grow larger and they know
within the White House the president
likes to retweet supportive surrogates
the White House keeps saying mr.
president let us build you a surrogate
team coordinated with the legal team so
there's more people on TV that you can
find defending you the president says no
I'm the key defender he wants to tell
the country I'm the only witness that
matters and for now at least that
strategy will continue major as you know
Ivanka Trump weighed in on the
impeachment fight for the first time
tweeting a quote from Thomas Jefferson
referencing about being surrounded by
enemies and spies and Washington I think
she ended it with some things never
changed dad so what do you make of that
and how is it being received indeed
clearly a not-so-veiled reference to
people who work within the Trump White
House who have
willingly to testify before the house
impeachment inquiry so that means there
is some dissatisfaction or sense of
being surrounded by people who are
disloyal one thing I would point out
about that quote it was Thomas Jefferson
in a letter he wasn't even president yet
it was before he was inaugurated so the
spies and things weren't setting him as
president the next line I think is
interesting also in the very same letter
I pant for that society where all this
peace and harmony where we love and are
beloved by every object we see not then
a long way to go may the panting
continue Thank You major